[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing
the deathly hallows and the beloved
ruby's handgrid
hogwarts keeper of keys and grounds more
specifically
we're going to be diving in to what
exactly happened to hagrid after the
battle of hogwarts and the end of the
second wizarding war
apart from the brief epilogue when the
last book film ended
we weren't given much more info with
regards to what exactly happened
to most of the surviving characters we
see harry
ginny hermione ron malfoy and more
sending their children after hogwarts at
platform nine and three-quarters
but hagrid is nowhere to be seen so what
came of the gentle giant
where did hagwood go when the chaos
ended and all of the dust
settled as much as i love sirius black
hagrid was
in my eyes harry's true father figure
he was there for him right from the
beginning of his life and carefully
watched over him as he grew
from a young boy to a young man hagrid
was the one who introduced harry to the
wizarding world
he showed him the ropes and he even
bought harry hedwig he's also the one
that grabbed harry from the potter
residence
and brought him to privet drive
teary-eyed as he left harry on the
dursley's doorstep
with no close family relationships in
his life a father that died
the mother that left harry was all
hagrid had and hagrid's care for harry
was shown in his actions and behavior
throughout the series after the
wizarding war ended
many people were left uncertain of their
next cause of action
as many of the people they knew and
loved had died though the good guys
emerged victorious
hogwarts was in shambles and many
relationships had been severed
hagrid's closest relationships were with
harry dumbledore and the school
and both the school at least temporarily
and
dumbledore were down for the count so
what did hagrid do next
it turns out that hagrid simply
continued working at hogwarts in his
usual posting
the only thing that hagrid loved more
than hogwarts was his love of magical
creatures
which explains why he would choose to
continue on as professor for care of
magical creatures
at the school hagrid is also referenced
in the epilogue by harry
while speaking to his son albus bye al
said harry as his son hugged him don't
forget hagrid's invited you to tea next
friday
don't mess with peeves don't duel anyone
until you've learned how
and don't let james wind you up the
epilogue of harry potter gave us a
glimpse of 19 years into the future
which would make the year 2017 and
hagrid 89 years old
however thanks to the longevity of
wizard kind i'm sure that hagrid
was still very sprightly in addition to
teaching at hogwarts
it's been suggested that hagrid may have
at one point further pursued a
relationship with madame maxime
however the two eventually proved to be
too different to make things work
we don't have much more info on the
gentle half giant other than this
but i hope this gives you some closure
with regards to hagrid's character
he's still alive and well to this day
and the ripe age
of 93 that's it for this video until
next time
you're a wizard harry
you